un bon soir mardi 9 février bienvenue
dans le journal de la rédaction de tv
soixante dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres
la neige et le verglas pourrait
s'inviter de nouveau dans les yvelines
le département a été placé en alerte
orange pour ses phénomènes ce fme
phénomène par météo france
il pourrait tomber à localement jusqu'à
10 cm de neige suivie d'une vague de
froid ont fait le point dans cette
édition en france 33% des étudiantes ont
besoin d'un soutien financier pour
acheter des protections périodiques la
précarité menstruel a été amplifiée avec
la crise sanitaire
une association de l'université
versailles saint quentin se mobilisent
face à ce constat tout comme la région
ile-de-france qui déploient des
distributeurs gratuits dans les lycées
alexandra dublanche vice présidente de
la collectivité est notre invité enfin
immersion à la fin de ce journal au
coeur d'un exercice des pompiers du
grimp des yvelines un entraînement sur
pylône à haute tension a été organisée
récemment à guerville c'était en
collaboration avec le groupe rtl
gestionnaire du réseau de transport
d'électricité à la fin de ce journal
également à suivre la mobilisation de
plusieurs habitants au vésinet suite à
la mort d'un jeune cycliste de 16 ans
dans un accident de la route
si vous prenez la route ce soir la
vigilance est de mise un épisode de
neige débuté ce matin en bretagne
devrait faire son arrivée ce soir dans
les yvelines le département fait partie
et des 31 territoires placés en alerte
orange pour la neige et le verglas c'est
le cas dans toute l'ile-de-france
bonsoir mélanie poquet de la rédaction
de tv 60,18 je ne sais pas si vous
m'entendez
mélanie en tout cas vous êtes sur place
en bordure de la nationale 10 au niveau
de trades quelle est la situation et
surtout quelles sont les prévisions pour
les prochaines heures
orange
elle a débuté à 18 heures mettrait météo
france prévoit entre 7 et 8 cm de neige
voire 10 cm plus localement
l'épisode devrait durer jusqu'en fin de
matinée de mercredi
les températures seront aussi très
froides mélanie et oui alors des
températures des gelées seront
généralisés dans toute l'île de france
les températures devraient descendre
jusqu'à 6 degrés mercredi matin dans
tout le département
et puis le service hivernal de saint
quentin en yvelines vous informe des
opérations de salage et de déneigement
et vous donne les alertes préfectoral si
vous voulez bénéficier de ces alertes
sms n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire via le
site 7 points ce qui point fr une
intervention a d'ailleurs débuté à 18h
et les saleuses ressortiront dans le
courant de la nuit et on a appris
mélanie dans l'après midi que la
préfecture des yvelines avait pris des
mesures de restriction de circulation
oui à partir de 20 heures les poids
lourds de plus de 7 tonnes fois que ne
pourront plus de circuler la limitation
de vitesse sera t-elle adc et il sera
perdu de dépasser et dès 21h la n118
sera complètement interdite à la
circulation pour tous les types de
véhicules
les transports scolaires sont suspendus
sur cette 1re journée du mercredi 10
février
la préfecture des yvelines conseille de
privilégier les transports en commun
d'ailleurs que par rapport aux
transports scolaires certaines écoles
également du territoire seront fermés
demain vous référer pour ce faire aux
mairies afin de connaître toutes les
différentes fermetures merci mélanie
pour toutes ces précisions et merci
également à bixente maria centriste est
bonne
qui était au cadre a pour ce duplex vous
l'entendiez des chutes de neige
attendues et aussi une vague de froid
qui s'abat sur le territoire des
yvelines et sur la région ile de france
avec des températures négatives en
conséquence 422 places d'hébergement
d'urgence supplémentaires ont été
ouvertes en ile de france pour les sans
abri annonce de la préfecture de région
est de 287 place ont été débloqués hier
ce mardi soir 135 lits supplémentaires
seront mises à disposition
cent trente six mille personnes sont
hébergées actuellement tous les soirs en
ile de france et dont 25 milles rien
qu'à paris le comité 19 toujours plus
présents dans les établissements
scolaires le sacré-coeur collège privé
de versailles a fermé ses portes hier
décision motivée par la direction suite
à la découverte sur place de quatre cas
positifs chez les élèves et des cas
provenant des variants on apprend par
ailleurs que neuf professeurs et 65
élèves du lycée louis de broglie de
marly-le-roi son talent isolement suite
à un cas positif du variant anglais
ducobu 19 également détecté sur place
avec nous à présent visioconférence
alexandra dublanche bonsoir ça vous êtes
vice président de la région ile de
france chargée du développement
économique et de l'attractivité de
l'agriculture et de la ruralité on parle
avec vous d'un sujet c'est la précarité
menstruel la région ile de france est
engagée sur le sujet on y vient dans un
instant à l'université ce chiffre
d'abord 33 pour cent des étudiantes
seraient concernés par le fait que
phénomène pour lutter constate contre
cette précarité l association poèmes de
l'ue vs qu à acheter des milliers de
protection aux périodiques qui seront
bientôt distribuées chaque bénéficiaire
sera invité à faire un don selon ses
moyens pour permettre la continuité de
ce projet le sujet d'astrid bergère et
des lots nord sinoquet difficile
d'acheter ces protections hygiéniques
quand on est étudiante
face à la précarité menstruel des
étudiants en médecine de l'université
versailles saint quentin en décidé
d'agir grâce à poèmes leur association
des protections seront bientôt
distribuées aux étudiantes une
distribution ça dure toute une journée
et on va classer les différentes
protections avec des affiches pour
expliquer comment fonctionne chaque
protection quels sont ses avantages et
ses inconvénients et on laissera du coup
les étudiants de choisir et elles
pourront faire un don libre en fonction
de ce qu'elle pense et ce qu'elle
aimerait donner des subventions de l'ue
vs cul du crous et la fage ont permis
d'acheter pour soixante mille euros des
serviettes lavables et jetable de tampon
et de cup
cette action fait suite à un sondage
réalisé en février 2020 c'est ressorti
qu'il y avait à peu près 20%
d'étudiantes qui avait dû bricoler une
pro tour une fortune par manque de
moyens à ce moment là donc c'est assez
énorme sur ce campus est à peu près neuf
pour cent des étudiantes ont déjà dû
choisir entre acheter soit des
protections menstruel soit un autre
produit de première nécessité comme par
exemple de la nourriture par la suite
l'association aimerait aussi étendre ses
actions
organiser des ateliers pour apprendre à
coudre ses propres protection lavables
ou encore intervenir dans les écoles
pour lever les tabous sur les
menstruations
et cette précarité menstruel touche
aussi les lycéennes 130 mille ans en
france
rattray régulièrement les cours pour
cette raison selon une étude de la
marque all ways qui date de 2018 en
ile-de-france 6% des jeunes filles
seraient également concernées on parle
de ce sujet avec alexandra dublanche
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france qui est avec moi par
visioconférence la région a commencé à
déployer des distributeurs gratuit de
protections hygiéniques dans les
établissements du territoire les à 465
lycées publics devraient en être équipés
à terme déjà pourquoi cette action quels
sont les objectifs
alors vous l'avez dit et la précarité
mon stress est une réalité quotidienne
pour nombreuses francilienne est à peu
près une jeune fille sur trois n'est de
france qui ne changent pas suffisamment
de protection ou à un recours à des
protections de fortune d'après des
études et donc ça a évidemment un impact
sur la vie scolaire est également et des
conséquences son décrochage scolaire
parce qu'ils nous donnent au mit et
pendant leur paie ghosn au sein des
galets et pécresse et nike stable pour
laquelle on a voulu agir en en place ces
distributeurs de salles est hygiénique
et de tampons bio gratuit évidemment
pour l'instant dans 30 baby cependant
ces publics et depuis cet automne et on
va le généraliser comme vous l'avez dit
allez 1 465 lycées publics de la région
pour un coût total d'un million d'euros
mais la problématique sur sur justement
ce sujet c'est lé coût de ces
protections qui peuvent être difficiles
à assumer pour pour les familles
exactement il ya des jeunes filles qui
ne sont pas en mesure de se les acheter
et c'est ça peut avoir un point
important dans un budget et donc sa
raison pour laquelle on met à
disposition et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on va l'étendre aussi aux
universités je me réjouis qu'il y ait
aussi des initiatives associatives
nous on vient de voter la semaine
dernière un grand plan contre la
précarité étudiante et dont une mesure
d'extension aussi dit aux universités
aux résidences étudiantes de ses
distributeurs de protections périodiques
puisque il y aurait à peu près a bien vu
cette nuit une femme seraient touchés
par la précarité dans ce truc j'étais
juste semaine justement c'est un
phénomène qui malgré son ampleur reste
assez peu visible
bhl d'après vous il ya toujours un tabou
autour de cette question
peut-être même si on voit qu'il est en
train d'être levés et tant mieux nous on
a des évidemment des bons retours ça
veut dire qu'il y avait un vrai besoin
et donc on sent que ça répond vraiment à
une angoisse et objectivement sur un
sujet dont on n'osait peut-être pas trop
parler l'idée c'est aussi qu'ils aient
une dimension sociale et pédagogique
autour de l'installation de ces
distributeurs il ya la possibilité pour
les établissements de mettre en oeuvre
des projets éducatifs justement pour
briser ce tabou exactement tasse on est
toujours en partenariat avec les lycées
avec d'autres d'autres actions vient en
complément et puis je tiens aussi à
ajouter que c'est protection elles sont
hors matériaux biologiques source et
traçable pour vraiment que tout le monde
ait accès à des produits aussi de de
qualité c'est important donc voilà or
aujourd'hui ce sont 31 lycéens dans la
région ile-de-france qui sont équipés de
ces distributeurs l'idc vous disiez tout
à l'heure de les déployer à l'ensemble
des lycées publics de la région
exactement nous avons 465 laisser
publics en ile de france et tous seront
dotés d'ici la fin de l'année de ses
distributeurs
donc c'est un coup à peu près d'un
milliard d'euros pour la région ile de
france puisque les lycées privés sous
contrat pourrait être aussi concernés
alors faudra voir effectivement s'ils en
font la demande c'est quelque chose qui
est envisageable tout à fait et vous en
avez parlé également l'investissement
sur sur cette thématique de la région
ile-de-france qu'elle est il un million
d'euros et on va également le faire pour
les universités les résidences
étudiantes s et le budget sera décidé au
mois d'avril lors d'un prochain conseil
régional merci alexandre dut blanche
d'être face et en plateau en
visioconférence je rappelle quatrième
vice présidente de la région ile de
france
c'était au vésinet le 11 janvier dernier
un jeune de 16 ans se rendant au lycée à
vélo décède des suites d'un accident
avec un poids lourd ce drame a choqué la
population qui s'est mobilisée par la
suite pour alerter sur les dangers de
cet axe de circulation
une pétition a même été lancée
rassemblant près de trente mille
signataires le reportage de bixente n'a
rien senti steban c'était au vésinet le
11 janvier dernier un jeune de 16 ans se
rendant au lycée à vélo décède des
suites d'un accident avec un poids lourd
ce drame survenu sur la route de croatie
a choqué la population qui s'est
mobilisée pour alerter sur les dangers
de cet axe de passage
une pétition a été lancée rassemblant
près de trente mille signataires elles
demandent l'amélioration urgente des
conditions de circulation pour les vélos
au vésinet en plus d'alertés bien sûr
nous voulons qu'ils aient des choses
concrètes
on demande
que les allées les camions du chantier
soit arrêtée pendant les horaires de
l'école en veut une piste cyclable
provisoire pour les enfants et aussi que
les chauffeurs de camion collège
l'itinéraire pour ne plus prendre les
petites rues du vésinet la route est
très peu aménagé son trafic important
aux heures de pointe rend l'accès encore
plus dangereux alors que c'est une voie
rapide d'accès au lycée pour les élèves
il ya un petit peu tout je dirais que
c'est la concentration qui fait la
dangerosité un don cas les voitures qui
sont garés il ya les bus les camions les
lycéens qui sont pressés d'aller aux
cours
donc tout ça dans une période en fait
très très limité malgré tout entre 7h30
et 8h30
des contacts ont été établis entre les
parents d'élèves et la mairie du vésinet
afin de discuter des dispositifs à
mettre en place comme axe principal
d'études interdire la circulation des
camions qui transitent sans autorisation
et remarques qui sont faits dans cette
pétition sont extrêmement justifier on y
adhère d'ailleurs à 100% ça correspond
parfaitement à notre un autre à notre
philosophie est un autre projet et que
l'on s'est mis d'accord avec le
promoteur immobilier enfin l'écran paris
aménagements pour pour que en plus de
ces contraventions de police municipale
et une pénalité qu'ils soient appliqués
aux promoteurs question qu une récidive
c'est là que le contrat est cassé et le
le marché est arrêté d'autres mesures à
court et moyen terme sont envisagées
créer un circuit vélo alternatif
renforcer la signalisation pour ensuite
construire une piste cyclable des
objectifs déjà énoncées dans le
programme de la liste électorale de
bruno corps à des ti élus lors des
dernières municipales avec
fondamentalement le développement des
pistes cyclables devraient puisse aussi
que la mauvaise idée après simplement
des tracés sur la route assurer la
sécurité des cyclistes la sécurité des
piétons et donc à terme revoir tout le
plan de circulation mais surtout limiter
la vitesse très fortement à l'intérieur
de l'usiné
des dispositifs à mettre en place en
urgence avec les retards de chantier sur
la zone le trafic risque encore
d'augmenter jusqu'à juin c'était au
vésinet du changement dans les
formations les dut auparavant délivrés
par les iut se transforme et deviennent
les b ut rassurez vous pour les
acronymes c'en est terminé les buts et
ce sont les bachelor universitaire de
technologie et cette transformation se
fera à partir de septembre 2021 si le
contrôle continu reste intégral et des
modifications sont prévues dans le
cursus
interview express collectées par astrid
bergère
[Musique]
on passe de 2 à 3 ans ce qui permet
d'obtenir le grade de licence et être
beaucoup plus conforme à l'enseignement
au niveau européen on augmente le nombre
de projets projet tutoré de façon à
améliorer
l'acquisition des compétences et enfin
on continue à avoir une forte
implication au sein des entreprises
puisque les étudiants de but est de
passer un stage allant de 22 à 26
semaines sur l'île et troisième sur le
site de vélizy on a autour de mou des
entreprises très tournée vers le
numérique et c'est le cas des formations
du site de vélizy on a d'informatique de
réseaux télécoms génie électrique et
métiers de multimédia et d'internet et
donc on va on va essayer d'avoir
davantage d'interaction avec ses
entreprises pour pour mieux coller à
profil au profil attendu
en ce qui concerne ut de l'elysée en
juillet il ya 450 places à peu près 450
places qui sont qui sont offertes pour
cette rentrée on aurait sur les mêmes
mêmes flux que les années passées avec
la dignité mais focus à présent dans ce
journal sur une entreprise implantée
depuis 2009 à bois d'arcy h2 pharma est
le premier producteur de sirop
génériques en france et la société
souhaite se développer grâce au fonds de
relance de la région ile-de-france dont
elle va bénéficier mélanie poké 50
millions d'unités créés chaque année h2
pharma est le premier producteur
français de spécialités pharmaceutiques
non stériles henry hassid dans son
entreprise en 1984 il est tout juste
diplômé et s'installe à cachan dans le
val de marne
notre spécialité c'est de développer de
produire tout ce qui va être liquidée
dans un flacon autrement dit tout ce qui
est siro et tout ce qui est bonne bouche
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes leader en
france et nous continuons à développer
des nouveaux produits pour sortir est
large et un petit peu notre panoplie de
produit h2 pharma emploie une
quarantaine de salariés la société
souhaite s'agrandir en lançant deux
projets nous avons décidé et cette
extension et le développement de ce
laboratoire et de cette structure high
tech pour le service aux laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et une opportunité a
fait que nous avons récupéré un autre
bâtiment que nous allons revampé
entièrement pour faire une nouvelle
unité de production h2 pharma a
sollicité la région pour bénéficier du
fonds de relance elle se voit doté d'une
aide de 800 mille euros la plus
importante de ce fonds on a perdu
beaucoup d'emplois industriels ces
dernières années et enfin sur 25 ans et
est donc du coup avec des conséquences
économiques et sociales très importante
donc nous on veut faire notamment
revenir de l'industrie en ile de france
on parle beaucoup de souveraineté
industrie lancement notamment dans le
domaine des médicaments et aider cette
industrie à se moderniser
et à se transformer pour créer de
l'emploi et être leader sur tout un tas
de marché une aide qui pourrait créer 30
emplois avec des investissements prévus
sur les deux prochaines années sa
capacité globale de production sera de
140 millions d'unités immersion à
présent au sein de l'unité grimp des
pompiers des yvelines c'est le groupe de
reconnaissance et d'intervention en
milieu périlleux le grimp amené
récemment à guerville un exercice sur un
pylône de haute tension électrique en
collaboration avec des agents du groupe
rte nicolas landry a suivi cet
entraînement ils sont cinquante agents
rte en ile de france spécialisée dans la
maintenance sur ce type d'infrastructure
des interventions sur des pylônes de
haute tension électrique avec des
risques d'accident c'est face à ce genre
de situation que le groupe réseau de
transport d'électricité collabore avec
les pompiers des yvelines des
entraînements de sauvetage en eau des
infrastructures avec l'unité grimpe 78
la figuration beau le voyait en v dual
au dessus de nous on a un ouvrier soit
un ouvrier rpe un ouvrier qualifié qui
est sur son baudrier qui est amarrée
d'accord il présente une douleur au
niveau de la jambe il est conscient il
est en contact avec son équipier qui est
au dessus
je veux qu'il faut accompagner un
informateur
fort donc qu'ils sont
verticales le plus simple c'était de
faire un système d'amarrage au dessus de
lui
ce qui est une ce qui est facile sur des
structures métalliques comme selon et de
le descendre à la verticale sur son
baudrier accompagner la docteure le
grimp c'est le groupe de reconnaissance
et d'intervention en milieu périlleux
des pompiers
ils interviennent pour évacuer des
victimes dans des environnements risqué
ce partenariat entre le se disent des
yvelines et rte permet une
complémentarité des spécialités
le principal risque propre ouvrage c'est
le risque d'électrification du coup les
pompiers sont très demandeurs et on
essaye de les former aux procédures
d'intervention pour qu'ils interviennent
en toute sécurité et de travailler un
simple ça permet de garantir la sécurité
de tous on peut pas se permettre
d'intervenir sur un pylône ou sur un
câble sans être sensibilisés à ce risque
électrique donc le partenariat rte est
important pour cette connaissance là que
nous on n'a pas nous après on prend le
relais sur la connaissance cordes
hauteur dans les yvelines l'unité du
grimp est composée de 36 pompiers
déployés dans les casernes du
département avant de vous laisser je
vous rappelle cette information les
yvelines placer ce soir en vigilance
orange à la neige et au verglas
l'épisode doit durer jusqu'à demain
mercredi en fin de matinée à 10 cm
attendus localement conséquence les
transports scolaires seront suspendus
demain dans les yvelines certaines
écoles fermées est la préfecture des
yvelines conseille de privilégier les
transports en commun d'ailleurs le
groupe rte gestionnaire du réseau
électrique avec qui nous étions dans le
précédent reportage l'assurent il n'y
aura pas de black out durant l'épisode
de neige et de vague de froid à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement électrique
n'est pas à risque la consommation des
français devrait rester en dessous du
pic hivernal enregistré en janvier rte
avait alerté l'an dernier sur la
vigilance particulière quant à
l'approvisionnement électrique en
période de grand froid la maintenance
des réacteurs nucléaires de nucléaire
ayant été perturbée par la crise
sanitaire voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant retrouvez le 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier très belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]